[Music]
on this monday night
declined some people are turning away
moderna's coveted shot
what's behind the injection rejection
moderna is a very good vaccine
the dose is in danger of being dumped in
canada
while the u.s records an onslaught in
new cases
nothing but turbulence the sos from the
troubled travel agency industry
invasion of grasshoppers they will all
die and you'll see it's like a graveyard
of grasshoppers but within 36 hours
thousands more have come back and
alberta city gets
bugged big time and going for women's
soccer gold at the olympics
canada kicks the u.s out of contention
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us on this august long
weekend which
signals the last stretch of summer and
while the pandemic may not be top of
mind for many canadians enjoying their
time off
health experts say what we do right now
is going to determine
what we face this fall new data shows we
are at the start of a fourth wave
driven by the highly transmissible delta
variant
canada's top doctor says this country
needs to raise its vaccination firewall
to better protect for this fall canada
has received more than 66 million
coveted 19 vaccine doses enough to
fully immunize every eligible person in
this country
but the number of people getting their
first dose in recent weeks
has stalled at 81 percent there is still
a lot of vaccine hesitancy
and now pharmacists in ontario are
warning thousands of moderna doses
could go to waste because people aren't
showing up for their shots
the reason brand preference shawn o'shea
has our top story
in canada's largest city and most
populous province the question of
vaccine supply and demand has been
turned upside down
i think it's ridiculous only weeks ago
getting an appointment for a dose of
cova 19 vaccine
was a little like winning a lottery now
over
several thousand are set to expire on
august 6th
and that's because of the 30-day window
vaccine doses destined to be tossed out
wasting them and having to throw them
away because they've expired
is really one of those things that we
don't want to see happen canada is a
wash in vaccine supply
the problem a decline in those wanting
shots and now a growing consumer brand
preference
people are turning away when they find
out it's moderna or not showing up
it's not so much the modern has a bad
name it's just that pfizer has really
dominated the market in mrna vaccines
pharmacists say some customers are
worried that mixing and matching having
two different types of vaccines
will limit their travel opportunities
they're seeing people turned away from
cruise lines or certain caribbean
destinations
and that could also be contributing to
some of the hesitancy around
moderna i just don't understand why they
don't
like the moderna the fact that we're
seeing vaccines getting wasted
it's a pity with only a billion of seven
billion vaccinated around the world so
far
this woman who's had one dose of each
says it's wrong i've immigrated here
from pakistan
people are dying there and they don't
have access to moderna i have a moderna
and a pfizer
and you know i'm happy to be fully
vaccinated at this moment
how to avoid waste we should be right
now talking to
other countries to say what do you need
what can we help with can we donate
not practical for supplies expiring this
week say pharmacists
their association has asked the ontario
government to authorize a third booster
shot
rather than throw out the doses elderly
senior folks
those are in high risk populations for
those still on the fence
that moderna is a very good vaccine it's
equally as good as the pfizer vaccine
there's no real difference
shadow shea global news toronto
the u.s is facing a similar vaccine
problem
too much supply and not nearly enough
demand
vaccination sites are sitting empty as
hospitals fill up due to soaring cases
driven again by the delta variant in
florida there are now more people
hospitalized than
any other point in the pandemic and as
jackson proskow reports america's top
doctors warn
things are about to get worse at a
weekend fair near st
louis a pop-up vaccination clinic sat
empty for two whole days
in a state with one of the lowest rates
of vaccination and highest rates of new
covet cases
not a single person walked through the
doors i am surprised by that i wish more
people would get vaccinated your grandma
and grandpa seemed fine
down the road in branson missouri billy
barker and six-year-old brody now wait
anxiously outside a hospital window
thirty-one-year-old daryl barker is on
the other side of the glass
battling severe covid and strong regret
i was strongly against to get the back
seat just because
we're a strong conservative family
but that little boy out there is a
reason to have a bag
as the virus rips its way through the
nearly 100 million americans who are
still
unvaccinated a dangerous fourth wave is
growing
rapidly driven by the delta variant the
numbers that we're seeing
are are unbelievable they're just
unbelievably frightened
incredibly there are now more coveted
patients in florida hospitals than at
any prior point in the pandemic
surpassing records set before vaccines
were available
100 of the people in my icu in the
intensive care unit
are unvaccinated the strong uptick in
cases and hospitalizations has prompted
some renewed interest in immunization
70 percent of adult americans are now at
least partially vaccinated
a milestone reached one month later than
expected
americans are seeing the risk and impact
of being unvaccinated
and responding with action but vaccine
uptake remains uneven
giving the virus and its more virulent
strain plenty of places to spread
unchecked across the u.s the places with
the lowest rates of vaccine acceptance
are on track to experience their worst
days yet
jackson prosko global news washington
another major health concern in this
country is the smoke from wildfires
environment canada's issued an air
quality advisory for metro vancouver and
the fraser valley
due to smoke from fires in the
province's interior and
neighboring washington state the haze is
expected to blanket the region for the
next day or two
with more than 240 fires burning
throughout bc
many areas are already dealing with
thick smoke the air quality is also a
concern in parts of western ontario
manitoba and saskatchewan all four
provinces
are experiencing an above average number
of wildfires this season
as climate change intensifies hot dry
conditions
to the tokyo games now and a historic
win in soccer
for the first time ever canada will play
in the olympic
gold medal game for women's soccer the
team
upset the number one ranked u.s for its
first win against the americans
since 2001. now the canada-us rivalry
has deep roots
with the u.s winning most of the matches
but as crystal gamansing reports
it was canada's turn for a dramatic
victory
jesse fleming likes the motto play every
game like it's your last
if this was the 23 year old's final
soccer moment
it was a player's dream come true the
americans are a
force on the pitch having won four gold
medals in the last
six summer olympics but that one goal by
fleming
was enough to take the game a victory
that made former teammate kalyn
kyle emotional they put blood sweat and
tears into this so
i've been there and i knew how much it
meant for the bronze medal i can't even
imagine being in a gold medal final
um so i'm like again i wouldn't have
missed the game for the world
team captain christine sinclair is the
world's leading goal scorer with 187
goals in international play
but she handed the ball to fleming maybe
she knew fleming's foot was still hot
after scoring a penalty shot against
brazil
to help get canada to the semifinals and
jessie's
young but she's an experienced player
but sync knows the program is going to
need players like her to step up when
sync's not there anymore
head coach bev priestman has said all
along they were looking to change
the color of their metals
the canadians have two bronze medals
from back to back olympics
on our day this team can can go all the
way that's what i gen
i genuinely feel that i think we have to
show up to every game to do that and it
is difficult nobody i keep saying that
the players nobody's going to hand us a
medal
getting by sweden won't be easy but no
matter what the canadians
have upgraded their medal should they
win gold
it will be historic the match goes
friday at 11 a.m in japan
that's 10 p.m eastern thursday night in
canada
crystal gomencing global news london
and that gold medal game will make
history for canada for another reason
25 year old midfielder quinn will become
the first
openly transgender and non-binary
athlete
to win an olympic medal they came out
publicly as transgender in a social
media post
last fall saying they want to be visible
to queer folks who don't see people like
them
on their feed and weightlifter laurel
hubbard has
made her mark at the games she is the
first openly transgender woman to
compete in an olympic weightlifting
final
despite being a metal contender she
could not complete a lift
metal is now out of reach for the new
zealander in the women's over
87 kilogram division hubbard thanked her
supporters for their love and
encouragement
and the ioc for being inclusive
two mental hopefuls who withdrew from
olympic events last week are
participating in tuesday's women's
balance beam final
canadian ellie black and american simone
biles are scheduled to compete for a
medal
black pulled out from the all-around
final after spraining her left ankle in
training
files the star of the gymnastics team
stepped away from competition to focus
on her mental health
she missed five events the international
olympic committee is investigating the
gesture
a u.s athlete made on the podium after
receiving her silver medal
shot putter raven saunders raised her
arms
in an x a potential breach of rules
banning protests on metal podiums
saunders says the gesture represents
solidarity with people who are black
lgbtq2
and who have struggled with mental
health she says american athletes have
been planning to protest for
several weeks the ioc has not specified
what penalties a violation might occur
the u.s olympic and paralympic committee
says the gesture
did not breach its rules the polish
government has granted a humanitarian
visa
to an olympic sprinter from belarus
christina timonovskaya feared for her
safety
after criticizing her coaching staff for
entering her into an event
she wasn't prepared for now this comes
nearly a year
after the country's disputed election
and as redmond shannon reports
since then belarusian authorities have
detained
and allegedly tortured government
critics
christina timinovskaya should have been
racing for belarus in the 200 meters on
monday
instead she was seeking refuge from her
own government
on sunday the sprinter said team bosses
drove her to the airport to board a
flight home
that after she criticized coaches for
entering her into the four by four
hundred meter relay
at the last minute an event she'd never
even raced before
japanese police guarded timminovsky at a
hotel
and then brought her to the polish
embassy monday where she was offered a
humanitarian visa
she's at the polish embassy
safe and in quite good condition
although the whole situation had a great
negative footprint on her
other belarusian athletes have
previously been fined
sacked or jailed for speaking out
against the government of authoritarian
leader
alexander lukashenka the ioc has refused
to recognize the president's
son as head of the belarusian olympic
committee
in the past year we've taken quite a lot
of action against the belarusian
noc um so we need to look at what they
tell us
and try to get an idea of what's what's
been going on
the team's head coach said that
timonovskaya's behavior was erratic
belarusian state tv called her actions a
cheap stunt
her husband has already fled to ukraine
it was
very dangerous for her because she
understands
they are under pressure and it possibly
dangerous
what may have started as a sporting spat
has now quickly moved into the sphere of
geopolitics
on the most high profile of stages and
it again highlights the atmosphere of
repression
and intimidation in belarus following
last year's
widely disputed election redmond shannon
global news
london the pandemic spelled the
departure of hundreds of travel agencies
coming up
the health the struggling industry is
now pleading for
as more canadians get vaccinated and
more restrictions ease
travel is making a big comeback in this
country and around the world
but for one tourism industry it could be
too late
travel agencies have suffered many
financial setbacks in this pandemic
and as karen lieberman reports many
might not survive much longer
without ottawa's help
canada's tourism industry is ready for
takeoff with travel being booked or
rebooked after covid 19 first crushed
plans and shut down borders
our company had 10 thousand
cancellations leaving travel agents like
richard van der lubbe scrambling
the re-bookings and the cancellations
and the rebookings
and then ultimately the winter vacations
being terminated altogether
and now we're going through the third or
fourth wave of this which is now the
refunds
travel may be making a slow comeback but
the damage has been done for travel
agencies
vanderlube closed all 25 of his
storefront locations
staff now work remotely across canada
more than 800 storefront agencies are
now permanently closed
the association of canadian travel
agencies or acta
estimates the industry's agencies and
agents are still seeing a revenue
decline
of 95 percent the last uh 16 months have
absolutely been devastating acta is
calling on ottawa to extend financial
support until the end of
2021. so far multiple kovid 19 benefits
will last through much of october
so today i'm announcing that we are
extending
the wage and rent subsidies and lockdown
support
until october 23rd
of this fall a much needed lifeline
because while travel agents may have
been busy throughout the pandemic
cancelling or
rescheduling they weren't actually
earning any income
travel agents aren't actually paid until
people leave and so there's no income
whatsoever
until at least later this year and into
2022. so it's tough times
and so i'll expect more closures as
vaccination rates increase and canadians
feel more confident making plans
the future for travel is bright for
those agencies that survive
travel is a pent-up demand people have
been dreaming about
it we just need help to get to the end
of 2021
karen lieberman global news toronto
caitlin conundrum had the crisis over a
small fish
with a big impact on the east coast
you're watching global national
a fishery in newfoundland and labrador
is facing big problems
over a small species important to the
ocean's food chain
capelin may not be as lucrative as crab
or lobster but they're still
worth millions to the province's
harvesters as ross lord explains their
numbers are nearing extinction
and that could lead to a devastating
domino effect
the capelin fishery in newfoundland and
labrador is small but
important it's open for one week per
year just as the capelin prepare to lay
their eggs
often on the shoreline at sea
fish harvesters scoop up 20 thousand
metric tons a year worth several million
dollars
egg-bearing females exported to japan
for sushi
but caplin's stocks are low just 4
percent of where they were in the 1980s
and there are calls to shut down the
fishery before they're totally depleted
from a wwf standpoint we are calling for
a total halt of the fishery the
reasoning
capeland are the main food source for
cod which were the lifeblood of
newfoundland and labrador before they
were overfished
and the commercial cod fisheries shut
down 30 years ago
this wildlife biologist suggests without
capelin
there's no comeback for cod it's
supporting our cod stocks
and you know i would look at the
termination of the capelin
fishery or at least the suspension is an
investment in our cod stocks
this department of fisheries and ocean
scientists says she shares those
concerns
but decisions on fish quotas fall to the
fisheries management branch of the
department
we just provide the advice we're not
involved in the final decision making
she says it's possible capelander being
depleted more by things like ice
patterns
ocean temperatures and salt content the
theory endorsed by the union for fish
harvesters
which brushes off critics the small
harvest that's important to
rural and coastal newfoundland and
labrador is
extremely small and they
should know if they don't that that's
not having any impact on the stock
whatsoever
dfo has cut the caplan quota by 25
this year a measure the world wildlife
fund says is not enough
and the fish union says is too much ross
lord
global news creepy crawly crisis
next why grasshoppers are invading parts
of southern alberta
first it was the pandemic then extreme
weather disasters
now it's grasshoppers hordes have
invaded lethbridge alberta following
weeks of hot and dry conditions
they're ravaging crops they're
terrifying residents and they're
multiplying beyond control
grasshoppers have swarmed the region
before but as heather ux west explains
it has
never been like this and there are fears
the worst
is still to come it's a sound that
residents of this west
lethbridge neighborhood can't seem to
escape the hop hop hop of grasshoppers
by the thousands
a constant presence in paige
thornborough's yard now
since early june in order for everyone
to actually want to eat we've had to
just you know
close our blinds we'll put on music so
we can't hear them because it's just
it's disgusting this morning
grasshoppers have kept thornboro's young
daughters from playing in the backyard
all summer
for crystal earl's family the
infestation is very much the
same my husband's he sprayed the yard
twice now
and they'll they will all die and you'll
see it's like a graveyard of
grasshoppers but within 36 hours
thousands more have come back they're
big yeah they are big
dan johnson has studied the grasshopper
population in southern alberta for years
when they began hatching in early june i
was seeing
20 per square meter which is already
concerning
by july 5th i was seeing places with 100
150 per square meter which is way past
the level of crop damage johnson says
the hot weather and drought conditions
has caused the grasshopper population
to explode the situation we're feeling
right now
is more of a result of the drought
which is drying up the agricultural
crops around the city
so the grasshoppers are moving into the
city more than they typically would
but as bad as things are this season
because all these grasshoppers are now
laying eggs for
next year summer 2022 could actually be
even worse the city says it doesn't
usually control for grasshoppers but
with climate change making canadian
summers
hotter and drier the parks department is
now looking into what can be done
if it's going to just you know get worse
next year and potentially worse the year
after that i think we need to have some
serious conversations in our family
about
you know is it worth is it worth it
being here still
the hordes of hoppers turning what
should be a backyard oasis
into a seemingly never-ending nightmare
heather urex west global news
lethbridge alberta even through the tv
it's enough to make your skin crawl
that is global national for this monday
i'm farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is a much nicer
site than that backyard in lethbridge
this is kootenay like in british
columbia
we love seeing your canada so please
email us your pictures at viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other